aujourd'hui tout le monde va prendre
pour son grade vous connaissez les
missions ingres agenda on adore orelsan
aussi il s'occupe de tout ce qui se
passe si je sais que je connais très
bien les missions aussi donc voilà vous
savez il s'occupe de tout ce qui se
passe en termes d'offre de tout ce qui
se passe en off donc regarder si vous
nous rejoignez encore sûr dit il ya
beaucoup de gens qui nous rejoignent de
nouvelles personnes tous les soirs
jean luc lemoine il va vous faire
découvrir un petit peu l'équipe mais
côté coulisses regarde je pense que je
vais les inquiéter oui je suis qu'une
question alors bonjour je m'appelle
monique je voudrais savoir si la belle
morini bosc était déjà folle avant de
rentrer dans votre équipe ou 6,7 à votre
contact cahier devenu comme ça isabelle
moi un immense
juan répondent à celles que je comprends
la question chère monique mai mais je
peux pas vous laisser dire ça il y
faisait belle n'est pas folle elle est
juste différente
par exemple c'est la seule qui peut
rester sérieuse en ayant une posture
ridicule c'est l aide aux gens qui
étaient mises en valeur et ça c'était
bien parce que ça change des cowboys
effectivement qu'on voit sur quelquefois
d'autres programmes où il ya un braquage
violence marseille tout ça là ça change
un petit peu de gens ça mais isabelle et
la fille du géant vert et on peut les
voir avec son père ils se tiennent comme
ça dans la famille et de temps il faut
justement en parlant de drouot
isabelle est aussi connue et reconnue
pour son rire attention les images
suivantes ont été réalisée sans trucage
ne touchez pas au volume de votre télé à
attention il ne reste plus que deux
isabelle morini bosc
oh la la
il revient fort
ça sort ça ne sort pas les oreilles le
problème d'isabelle que quand elle rit
et n'a pas de réseau on attend pas donc
pour lui redonner un peu de dignité
j'ai décidé de lui rajouter un rire
désolé j'ai trouvé career de bébé il
revient
oui il avait des différentes et surtout
je le dis pour vous et les fragiles
faire attention
la semaine dernière syrie faisait un
call est la question il s'appelle va
faire une proposition
et comme cyril avec un peu de ménage
mans va lui dire qu'elle a tort ce avec
le groupe de l'écran bleu mais regardez
la vie continue autour d'elle mais elle
elle va mettre trente secondes à
redémarrer ou pas du tout sophie marceau
c'est pas du tout sophie marceau mais
c'est non mais non non mais là c'est pas
mon âge pas elle que cherche c'est parce
que jaffe patricia kaas café pas fait ça
casse mais il est bon ou julien sage et
sérieux nouveau c'est pas du tout ça
merci c'est pas patrice et pas sophie
marceau que je veux c'est une star télé
des années 90 on l'avait reçue ici
yo ka fait de la vie flamand non non non
non non non elle joue sans les austères
de l'amour billetterie chalet de l'ordre
oui café julie pietri
mais faites gaffe on a failli la perdre
la gauche en fait c'est un domaine où
isabelle est toujours au top vous savez
c'est quoi c'est la danse à danser oui
c'est la danse pour le plus grand
bonheur vous allez voir de ses voisins
voir non
au derrière
comme ça
la veille il a peiné à la fois que les
dames en berceau heureux non allez vas-y
pour jean-michel nous ils parlent pas et
bien parce qu'il est difficile
jean-michel on l'a vu la semaine
dernière on sait il aime pas quand
gilles verdez une part de ski de fond
quand il abat elle lui parle de
badminton
heureusement cette fois ci il était à
côté de philippe vandel qui a des
théories passionnant sur la coiffure ça
ça l'intéresse jean-michel
avant quand j'étais jeune je suis sous
préfet et les mecs arrivait comme il
était
non
son voile mais comme les mêmes fuir avec
autant d'attention et d'énergie
knees l'attenté des filles
donc maintenant vous savez pourquoi on
met toujours agi à côté de jean michel
albareil parce que je chéris c'est le
seul qui trouve des bons sujets de
conversation là on regarder un extrait
de top chef ou envoyer un couple
cuisiner ensemble à 4,91 nous les jours
dont réuni away halal et iris et la
mitraillette à vannes
cécile de ménibus elle pose les bonnes
questions
on la connaît non elle fait pas ça non
quand même problème de thierry s'équiper
jamais s'arrêter
regardez le même pendant que cyril me
présente dakota et regardez le allegri
l'échiné et gris chiné
il est tout de grip et des chinois sur
tout excuser le ciné chinois s'est très
bien trouvé
champion du monde
d'emblée ça mérite une récompense alors
un des bons moments de la semaine
dernière c'est quand ton ami thierry
moreau dans les buts de hand et qu'on
l'a canarder ah oui je vais pas le
cacher ces moments que j'ai préféré
depuis la création de l'émission et
enora aussi d'ailleurs
elle a mis tellement d'ardeur bas bach
et ses gaufres et mais heureusement ça
s'est pas vu avait alesi merci de vous
retrouver série à
ils sont à 19h50 tous les samedis sur
canal+ un carrefour
telle équipe de bras cassés c'est
l'équipe la coca vous n'auriez pas bien
vu je vous ai fait un petit ralenti de
ce grand moment de sensualité
g
vous avez raison que des bras cassés il
n'a pas pour rattraper l'eau dans cet
écrit plateau car academy et encore je
monte pas tout non ba s'est montrée tout
alors pour vous vous rendez bien compte
du niveau général
je vous ai fait un top 3 des échanges
les plus étranges de la semaine a très
bien attention vous allez avoir des
conversations de prix nobel allait au
débat
les dso voilà nous
aïe aïe aïe aïe
caillou paul lafargue cailloux et on
28,6 aux feuilles les ciseaux coupe la
feuille ciseaux qui gagne à chaque fois
y en a qui gagnent 1 2 3 à la ses
batailles ciseaux ailleurs à y aller
m
si jamais vous préférez ont préféré
c'est quand même le premier bleu blanc
rouge ben on est tous copains chez vous
c'est qu'elle peut faire ça pendant des
heures heureusement pour relever tout ça
il y à gilles vers des biens sans doute
le meilleur de nous là pour un sketch
florent peyre demandé à l'un des
chroniqueurs de chanter c'est christophe
carrière qui s'est dévoué et après
gilles comme à son habitude le dit
franchement ce qu'il pensait de sa
prestation
alors je vous passe les extraits parce
que les mangeux de regarder plusieurs
fois cet extrait j'arrive toujours pas à
savoir si gilles est un gros faux cul ou
s'il a juste du caca dans les oreilles
télé plus qui re se dévouer christophe
lights budget c'est bien tout changer
je vais te dire un beau compliment je ne
sais pas ce qu'ils avaient préparé une
liste bien cela suppose que tu n'as pas
préparé les esprits mais c'est tout
c'est très bien c'est joli [ __ ] la
péta quatre mois donc j'ai trouvé que
terrassement bien vous chantez vachement
bien mais gilles verdez est étrange on
voit droit comme la justice il a la tête
d'un mec qui vient saisir tes meubles au
petit matin mais regardez j'ai le moment
précis où l'homme qui a mal à sa france
devient gilles le keeper vous allez voir
il se transforme en une seconde
c'est spectaculaire
bravo encore plus rapide que gilles
encore plus ringard jean-michel voilà
jean michel qui a inventé la danse de
deux secondes
alors la question départ était isabelle
morini bosc est elle folle non je vous
prouver que non même si c'est vrai que
parfois dit des choses étranges un
nouvel exemple
pardon j'ai raté quelques touristes avec
des noms aussi oui ah oui ça tout norme
unique
moi j'adore enseigner quoi de faire mal
oui ou de rire moi j'ai de rire
on ne pense pas mais c'est génial de
rire et de faire bien là et c'est près
de chez vous en faites vous saisira donc
non il elle n'est pas folle et ce pour
une bonne raison
parce que c'est si reed qui l'a recruté
et corse il est très équilibré regardez
le avant qu'on reçoive pierre bellemare
show avec mais tu as wen et obama
pierre bellemare pierre bellemare dont
la joie père bellemare pierre bellemare
pierre bellemare pierre bellemare ou
pierre bellemare bellemare de ketchup
chocottes
j'étais tout simplement
oui j'avais un vrai j'ai des amis je
vous le dis on comprend pourquoi des 8 a
tout misé sur cyril mais c'est vrai
c'est un mais bien dans sa tête et
surtout il est très créatif il fait
notre admiration à tous la preuve avec
cet extrait où cyril invente un nouveau
jeu comme ça pour le plaisir
attention je vous invite à senteur
sentez vous essayez de toledo qui sait
j'ai marché malissen la 5e et chantre un
pack le ciel cracher les bouffées de
havanes série s'est passée la gueule
mais je colère je bouffe est qu aujourd
hui
ce n'était pas moi je n'ai pas vu
c'était bien michel sardou bonjour je
m'appelle leïla pour fêter leur victoire
les handballeurs ont un cyril hanouna
torse nu j'ai pas compris le rapport
donc je voulais savoir si pour fêter le
record de renaud lavillénie cyril comté
cette semaine nous montrer sa perche